en format du vendredi dans un jour avec
ce soir un document inédit jean marc
collienne et laurent fignon nous font
découvrir la vie du centre de formation
des imams à la plaine des cafres
l'objectif de ce centre créé en 1996
former des imams réunionnais à la
réunion pour favoriser un islam apaisé
et éviter les dérives de l'islamisme il
est 5 heures du matin le jour n'est pas
encore levé sur la plaine des cafres
c'est une nouvelle journée de cours qui
commence pour les élèves du centre de
formation des imams
[Musique]
ammann ou la noria à 26 ans fils de
commerçants dionysiens qu'il en est à sa
septième et dernière année d'études
comme tous les matins c'est en récitant
déjà le coran qu'il va assister à la
première prière de la journée
dix mille
cette année le centre accueille soixante
élèves ils viennent de la réunion de
mayotte mais également de l'hexagone
la chine est une chaîne de prière et
d'étude que tu as choisi une vie en fait
c'est une vie de prière et d'étude
mais c'est aussi c'est à dire on n'est
pas séparée on n'est pas coupé du monde
réel
l'islam c'est ça nous apprend comment
nous comporter en fait avec autrui
comment nous comporter avec les parents
avec les amis comment travailler
honnêtement voilà on nous apprend les
bases on nous donne un cadre de vie
s'éteint tout en fait la plupart des
étudiants vite ici en internat le
confort est rudimentaire les nuits sont
froides
il n'y a pas de chauffage et tous les
matins chaque élève doit faire le ménage
et à côté un peu sévère militaire dans
cette vie oui c'est à dire en fait c'est
un c'est un mode de vie comme les
militaires quoi le matin voilà il faut
nous apprend justement à être à être
rigoureux à être propre à avoir une
hygiène de vie où nous avons la
simplicité à être simple à être à être
modeste à être humble et ça nous apprend
également à avoir de la pitié la
compassion pour les pour les plus
démunis
à tout le monde se dirige vers les
salles de cours voilà chacun chacun va
intégrer sa classe il ya également les
élèves qui sont externes sea king
[Musique]
c'est parti pour une matinée de cours
voilà il maintenant cours et le
programme est chargé six heures de cours
jusqu'à 12h30
ce matin la classe de 7e étudie les
récits du prophète
sinon le chapitre concernant la valeur
des compagnies profond la marina
capitale salman al alami moi ça ne m'a
ni moi j'ai passé le gestion la première
nantis ou qu'est-ce que jane robison
toute la matinée les cours vont se
succéder ainsi dix périodes de cours de
40 minutes pour les élèves de première
année
c'est l'heure de la grammaire arabe
qui le dit avant d'étudier le coran pour
en comprendre toutes les subtilités
les élèves doivent maîtriser la langue
arabe lire parler écrire et traduit il
me tarde et ici qu'est-ce que j'ai
conforme est de taille
[Musique]
toute la journée les élèves se succèdent
également dans la salle de prière pour
de longues séances de mémorisation des
6666 versets du coran zakaria gang at a
créé le centre de formation de la plaine
des cafres commerçants au tampon et
lui-même imams
il a étudié en inde et en afrique du sud
comme le faisait avant la plupart des
jeunes réunionnais qui souhaitait
devenir imam aujourd'hui il veut que ses
élèves connaissent parfaitement le coran
mais également l'histoire de france et
le droit français
il nous faut des hommes bien formés qui
ont la maîtrise du texte et qui ont
aussi la compréhension du contexte dans
lequel ils vivent
j'espère je pense que ça pourrait
limiter les dérives
parce que quand on voit souvent les
dérives c'est dû à internet
c'est dû au fait de se couper du monde
de ce coupé de la population musulmane
aussi des frères des soeurs et c est là
on sent brigade on rentre dans un
système et après arrivent les dérives
qui vient même sana in corpore sano
après les longues heures d'étude de la
matinée l'après midi est consacré aux
activités sportives
le centre fonctionne comme une école
privée
l'inscription annuelle coûte 1500 euros
mais la plupart des élèves n'ont pas les
moyens de payer cette somme
du coup l'essentiel du financement est
assuré par la communauté musulmane de
l'île
[Musique]
la journée au centre est rythmée par les
appels à la prière cinq fois par jour
ayala
et la soirée est encore consacré à
l'étude
[Musique]
de 18h à 21h les élèves révisent leurs
cours à la valeur
et après la dernière prière chacun va se
coucher
[Musique]
wa lâ ilâha illâ mois
le lendemain nous retrouvons amadou là
dans les jardins du centre de formation
à la fin de l'année il sera diplômé il
pourra officié comme imam mais il veut
aussi travailler à voir une femme des
enfants une vie simple bien loin en
apparence des troubles qui secoue le
monde musulman
toi tu n'as jamais souffert dans toute
cette période troublée du regard bien tu
l'a quand même ressenti que que c'était
par moments difficiles de de s'afficher
musulmans dans cette tenue avec la barbe
il y à il y as on a senti depuis
quelques années qu'il ya un regain qui a
quand même un peu changé mais c'est pas
virulent par moments on se sent on se
sent regardé par les gens mais après je
veux dire on ne va pas avoir honte avoir
honte de notre islam
ce n'est pas à cause de ces personnes là
pour 20
voilà qu'on va revenir et d'être notre
foi la chance qu'on a d'avoir cet
institut à la réunion pour le
réunionnais c'est qu'il peut vivre sans
sa créolité vivre son islam tout en
étant créole français c'est la tma
yamadou la joie le champ à la parole
avec ses prières composé sur maloya de
danyel waro comment faire pour avancer
et où tout se lit très beau la clé la
vie
il